let's look at the quote from from mark
zuckerberg
so uh at uh at 64 uh minutes and 31
seconds on the video i didn't encoded
this this is the this is excellent this
is the very helpful youtube transcript
youtube's an amazing program um you
asked him about francis haugen you give
him a chance to respond
uh and here's the key thing um
so he talks about what francis haugen
said he said no but that's
mischaracterized actually on most
measures the kids are doing better when
they're on instagram it's just on one
out of the 18.
and then he says
um i think an accurate characterization
would have been the kids using instagram
uh or not kids but teens is generally
positive for their mental health that's
his claim that youtube that uh instagram
is overall taken as a whole instagram is
positive for their mental health that's
what he says
okay um now is it really is it really uh
so first just the simple okay now here
what i'd like to do is turn my attention
to another document that we'll make
available um so i was invited to give
testimony before a senate subcommittee
two weeks ago uh where they were
considering the platform accountability
act should we force the platforms to
actually tell us what our kids are doing
like we have no idea other than
self-report we have no idea you know
they're the only ones who know like the
kid does this and then over the next
hours the kid's depressed are happy we
can't know that but but facebook knows
it um so should they be compelled to uh
to reveal the data we need that so you
raise just uh
uh to give people a little bit of
context in this document is brilliantly
structured
with questions studies that indicate
that the answer to a question is yes
indicate that the answer to question is
no and then mix results and questions
include things like the social media
make people more angry or effectively
polarized right
that's the one that we're going to get
to that's the one for democracy yes
that's so democracy so i've got three
different google docs here because i
found this is an amazing way and thank
god for google docs it's an amazing way
to organize the research literature and
it's a collaborative review meaning that
so on this one gene twenge and i put up
the first draft and we say please you
know comment add studies tell us what we
missed and it evolves in real time in
any direction the yes or the oh yeah we
specifically encourage because i look
my the center of my research is that our
gut feelings drive our reasoning that's
that was my dissertation that was my
early research and so if gene twenge and
i are committed to but we're going to
obviously preferentially believe that
these platforms are bad for kids because
we said so in our books so we have
confirmation bias and i'm a devotee of
john stewart mill the only cure for
confirmation bias is other people who
have a different confirmation bias so
these documents evolve because critics
then say no you missed this or they say
you don't know what you're talking about
said great say so tell us
um so i put together this document and
i'm going to i'm going to put links to
everything on my website if users if
you're sorry if listeners viewers go to
jonathanheight.com
socialmedia
it's a new page i just created i'll put
everything together in one place there
and we'll put those in the show notes
like links to this document and and
other things like it though that's right
exactly right so yeah so the thing i
want to call attention now is this
document this document here with the
title teen mental health is plummeting
and social media is a major contributing
cause
so ben sass and chris coons are on the
judiciary committee they had a
subcommittee hearing on uh nate
priscilli's bill uh platform
accountability transparency act so they
asked me to testify on what do we know
what's going on with teen mental health
and so what i did was i put together
everything i know with plenty of graphs
um to make these points that first what
do we know about the crisis well uh that
the crisis is specific to mood disorders
not everything else it's uh it's not
just self-report it's also behavioral
data because suicide and self-harm go
skyrocketing after 2010.
um the increases are very large and the
crisis is gendered
and it's hit many countries so i go
through the data on that so we have a
pretty clear characterization and
nobody's disputed me on this on this
part so can we just pause real quick
just so for people who are not aware so
self report just how you kind of collect
data on this kind of thing sure you have
a
self-reported survey you ask people uh
how yeah how anxious are you these days
yeah how many hours a week do you social
media
that kind of stuff and you do
it's maybe
uh you can collect large amounts of data
that way because you can ask a large
number of people that kind of question
and but then there's uh i forget the
term you use but more
uh some non-self report data behavioral
data behavioral data that's right where
you actually have self-harm
and
suicide numbers exactly so there are a
lot of graphs like this so this is from
the national survey on drug use and
health so the federal government and
also pew and gallup there are a lot of
of organizations that have been
collecting survey data for decades so
this is a gold mine and what you see on
these graphs over and over again is
relatively straight lines up until
around 2010 or 2012. and on the x-axis
we have time years going from 2004 to
2020 on the y-axis is the percent of u.s
teens who had a major depression in the
last year that's right so when this data
started coming out around so gene
twang's book igen 2017 a lot of people
oh she you know she doesn't know what
she's talking about this is just
self-report like gen z they're just
really comfortable talking about this
this is a good thing this isn't a real
epidemic and literally the day before my
book with greg was published the day
before uh there was a psychiatrist in
new york times who had an op-ed saying
relax cell phones uh smartphones are not
ruining your kid's brain and he said
it's just self-report it's just that
they're they're giving higher rates
there's more diagnosis but underlying
there's no change no because these gra
these it's theoretically possible but
all we have to do is look at the
hospitalization data for self-harm and
suicide and we see the exact same trends
we see also a very sudden big rise um
around between 2009 and 2012 you have an
elbow and then it goes up up up so then
that is not self-report those are actual
kids admitted to hospitals for cutting
themselves
um so we have a catastrophe and this was
all true before kovid cove had made
things worse but we have to realize you
know coverts going away kids are back in
school or back in school but we're not
going to go back to where we were
because this problem is not caused by
covid what is it caused by um well uh
just again to just go through the point
then i'll stop i i just feel like i'm i
just really don't want to get out the
data to show that marxism is wrong so
first point correlational studies
consistently show a link they almost all
do but it's not big
equivalent to a correlation coefficient
around 0.1 typically
that's the first point the second point
is that
this the correlation is actually much
larger than for eating potatoes so that
famous line wasn't about social media
use that was about digital media use
that included watching netflix doing
homework on everything and so what they
did is they they looked at all screen
use and then they said this is
correlated with self-reports of
depression anxiety at like you know 0.03
it's tiny
and well but they said that clearly in
the paper but the media has reported as
social media
is .03 or tiny and that's just not true
what i found digging into it you don't
know this until you look at the there's
more than 100 studies that hit the in
the google doc once you dig in what you
see is okay you see a tiny correlation
what happens if we zoom in on just
social media it always gets bigger often
a lot bigger two or three times bigger
what happens if we zoom in on girls and
social media it always gets bigger often
a lot bigger and so
what i think we can conclude in fact
what one of the authors of the potato
studies herself concludes amy orbin says
i think i have a quote from here she
reviewed a lot of studies and she
herself said that quote the associations
between social media use and well-being
therefore range from about r equals 0.15
to r equals 0.10 um
so that's the range we're talking about
and that's for boys and girls together
and a lot of research including hers and
mine show that girls it's higher so for
girls we're talking about correlations
around point one five to point two i
believe gene twangy and i found it's
about point two or point two two
now this might sound like an arcane
social science debate but people have to
understand
public health correlations are almost
never above point two so the correlation
of childhood exposure to lead and adult
iq very serious problem that's .09 like
the world's messy and our measurements
are messy and so if you find a
consistent correlation of 0.15 like you
would never let your kid do that thing
that actually is dangerous and it can
explain when you multiply it over
tens of millions of kids spending you
know years of their lives
you actually can explain the mental
health epidemic just from
social media use
well and then there's questions by the
way uh this is really good to learn
because i quit potatoes and it had no
time
uh
that was a big sacrifice um they had
quite literal actually because i'm
mostly eating keto these days but that's
that's
that's funny that they're actually
literally called the potato studies okay
uh but
given this and there's a lot of
fascinating data here
there's also a discussion of how to how
to fix it
what are the aspects
that if fixed would start to reverse
some of these trends
so if we just
linger on the sort of the mark
zuckerberg
statements
so first of all do you think
mark is aware of some of these
studies
so
if
you put yourself in the shoes of mark
zuckerberg and the executives that
facebook and twitter
how can you try to understand the
studies like the google docs you put
together
to try to make decisions that fix things
is
is is there a stable science now that
you can start to investigate and also
maybe
if you can comment
on the depth of data that's available
because ultimately
this is something you argue that the
data should be more
transparent should be provided but
currently if it's not
all you have is maybe some leaks of
internal data right that's right and we
could talk about the potential you have
to be very sort of objective about the
potential bias and those kinds of leaks
you want to it would be nice to have a
non-leak data like
like yeah it'd be nice to be able to
actually have academic researchers able
to access in de-individuated
de-identified form
the actual data on what kids are doing
and how their mood changes and and you
know when people commit suicide what was
happening before and it'd be great to
know that we have no idea
you